I believe feminism was created by Men by  the men at the top because they wanted  to have a 50 of the population that they  could tax so they could make more money  and then also like I said destabilize  the family unit so they want women out  of the home into the workplace so now  the children are left who's going to  take care of them the state easier to  indoctrinate easier to brainwash and  only looking back now at my childhood do  I see the indoctrination that I  experienced in schools it's like a  religious thing or yeah religious and  cultural yeah yeah you know they want  you to support certain ideas and they  really shove that down your throat as a  child the Leia Marathon show